sleep
foreign
there we go
um good afternoon time being just a
little after one o'clock today on the
13th I'd like to welcome all of you here
to uh Public Works and highways
I do not believe there's a better
Committee in this uh in this state than
the one that we are sitting with
um some of the some of the things that
come to mind is I have been here since
2002 on and off I'm starting my ninth
term I have had the pleasure of serving
as chair as Vice chair and once again as
chairman
um I think when we go through
introductions you're going to be
surprised some of the new members of
this committee to find out uh the
lineage here where so many have been
chairman and vice chairman of whether
it's this uh committee or others we're
the Hallmark for uh bipartisanship
we have I've served I think it's the
first time I've served more times under
Republican speaker than I have a
Democrat speaker our votes tend to come
out
nearly unanimous
uh we have a habit of trying to work
through and come out with something that
works for everybody
the speaker has asked that we mingle
Democrats with Republicans which we
always have anyways
um and um I'm just really looking
forward to getting started here again
I'm going to uh we'll go around the room
and introduce ourselves uh Christy I'm
sorry Christie your last name
offense is she is our committee research
person
and I have had to lean heavily already
and her guidance has been absolutely
tremendous
so I'll I will um I will start with
myself uh for the new members and give
you a little background as I said I was
first elected to this house in 2002 uh
I'm starting my ninth term here
I'm I own a business that I still
conduct a family business
my two sons my daughter I have a foreman
and another person that works with us so
that takes a bit of my time and the only
reason I can do this job for so many
years is because I have my family there
in support of me when I'm gone
I served as a zoning chairman in my town
in Ossipee for 14 or 15 years I served
on the Executive Board of the Lakes
Region Planning Commission I know
several of you have been in that
position so I have a lot of background
in that area
um
and that's pretty much myself I will
pass to the vice chairman okay thank you
Mr chairman I am a state I'm sorry I am
state representative John Cloutier from
Claremont I have served in the house
since 1992 and all but one term on this
committee but during that term I was on
on two different committees I came to
appreciate this committee even more as
you know uh and for many of the reasons
that the chairman has just alluded to
um but but also too I have served I I've
served as chair of this committee Vice
chair which I'm coming back in again a
clerk ranking member so I've practically
done held every position on this
committee that you can hold
uh I'd like to think that gives me some
experience and I think it does but I
also have found over the years that I
always learn new things serving on this
committee as well as the legislature in
the whole and I guess that's why I keep
running again and again and again and
thank goodness the voters of my area I
now represent not only Claremont but the
town of Croydon keep returning because I
guess they like what I do and they think
I'm effective uh and I think hopefully
this is a very bipartisan committee
overall we do have some disputes but
hopefully we've always been in the past
been able to settle them amicably and
without any lasting ill effects and
hopefully we'll do the same if we get
into any this year uh and it's my hope
to try to make sure that happens uh but
I think you'll look you'll enjoy your
experience here
and uh be feel free to to ask if you
have questions concern any the chairman
myself or any other member of the
committee or the staff I found them to
be always very helpful and look forward
again to working with you all for the
just tell them you you also have a
full-time job yeah I I actually well a
full-time job and actually two jobs I
mean I'm a full I'm a private security
officer I'm also a substitute teacher so
in addition to doing this I keep busy I
guess it's one good thing I'm not
married and don't have kids so I don't
have some of the responsibilities some
of you have uh so I'm very active but I
will always if you call me or email me I
will try to respond back to your call or
email within the within 24 48 Hours
afterwards
um so we're just we're just going seat
to seat tell us a little about yourself
and uh how long you've served and what
committees and if you've held a
leadership position
just push your uh
Tom Kaczynski on District Five Rochester
uh
this is my fourth term
served on the Eda Edna committee for
two terms and on this committee the last
term
uh
my main life is well I gotta
poultry business we ship into New York
City which keeps me busy pretty pretty
much eight days a week
that's why I'm a few minutes late here
today so
I guess that's about it thank you
we'll come back on the head table here
represent Mills
thank you Mr chair um David Mills uh
this is my sixth term here uh all on
public works I've been the this will be
my third time as the clerk I've been the
vice chair uh I don't have an outside
job I I started investing as a hobby and
I retired when I was 52 because I got
pretty good at my hobby so I don't work
and uh as as he's previously said I'm
from dairy uh I've served as their fire
commissioner I've served as a town
counselor I've I've been on every board
and commission that they have in the
town of dairy and uh
this is by far the most nonpartisan
committee there has ever been in this
state house and uh you should be happy
that you're on it thank you thank you
Marty
thank you Mr chairman I'm Marty Jack
from Nashua this is my sixth term in the
house and my sixth term on this
committee I have an engineering
background in software which is helpful
in a few different ways and I was Clerk
thank you we'll just keep going down the
uh thank you Mr chairman yeah my name is
Mike Edgar
um I came in in a special election so
this is my fourth and a half term
um I was very fortunate to get on the
Public Works committee at that time
I had to fight to get on it and I was
really glad I did my background is is
engineering I'm a professional engineer
and I did that work on the private side
and also in the military uh 26 years
with the Navy with the Seabees mostly in
the reserves
um as far as the town goes I've been in
different positions in the town School
Board
a bunch of different committees stuff
with the youth
judge of the uh we have a big Youth
Organization in Hampton and presently in
the uh an officer in the American Legion
in Hampton and also on on a couple other
committees so I just real feel fortunate
to be on the committee again
and uh yeah there was one time one of
the times I was the vice chair of the
committee when John was chair
good afternoon my name is Bill Boyd I I
excuse me I apologize representing
District 12 in the town of Merrimack
this is
like representative Edgar I came in on a
special election so this is probably my
one in seven eighths term I'm starting
as a consequence
um
really happy to be here on public works
and highways it's what I it's what I
sought out when I got elected to the
legislature my background I am a former
four-term Town counselor in Merrimack I
served on my planning board I served on
the Nashville Regional Planning
Commission and I was also elected to the
Merrimack School District budget
committee a long time ago
outside of Public Works and highways I
am also the chair of the New Hampshire
drinking water and groundwater advisory
commission I started doing that when it
came into its Inception back in 2016
when I was serving on the Merrimack Town
Council and working on that commission
like
chairman McConkey alluded to we do some
amazing work in a very strong bipartisan
manner in in the work that we accomplish
on the commission level gives gives me a
lot of satisfaction a lot of Joy this
we're doing we're doing some good work
God bless you
um personally been happily married to my
wife Michelle
she's a nurse anesthetist for 18 years
we have we have our adopted daughter her
name is Jade she is 21 currently a
junior at Southern New Hampshire
University studying psychology and Child
Development I like to run I'm a proud
Boston college graduate so any BC or
beanpot talk I'm usually up for and I
would say while the the weather this
winter has not been conducive to my
hobby my wife daughter and I are the
proud owners of the midnight run sled
dog racing kennel we have 23 active sled
dogs that we've been running around the
United States and Canada now for
ever since I married my wife some 18
years ago so I got 23 active athletes
and three retirees and lately they're
not snow dogs they've been dirt dogs
we've been over at beer Brook with our
with our cart and our ATV getting them
their exercise and training them up so
it's we're just been a little bit
disappointing but anyway that's a little
bit about me and really happy to be here
and I'll look forward to a very
productive session with all of you so
my name is Charles Melvin senior uh this
is my third term in the house my first
term I was on environment and
agriculture my second term I was on
Municipal and County
uh I am a selectman in my town I've had
two terms I've I spent 35 years on my
planner board and 15 years on my zba I'm
a justice of the peace I spent time on
the school board uh and I own and
operate well I don't operate anymore my
son does operate CNM auto repair in New
hi my name is Jim Connor
um I represent City of Rochester strap
in 19
um first term
State Rep
I am a member of the GBA in Rochester in
a historical district Mission I'm also
the vice president of the local lion
club
um I've been married for 31 years I
believe now and
um we have three grown boys all out of
the house which is a good thing so it's
just me and the wife now so and I don't
work so I got all kinds of time so
that's it for me thank you
foreign
first term from uh Hillsboro 7 in Nashua
I'm a mostly a full-time parent and I'm
a landlord as well I did 25 almost 25
years at the MBTA in in the engineering
department
and again this is my my first term and
I'm thankful to uh to be on this
committee and I appreciate all your
welcomes
hi my name is Michael Peterson I'm from
Nashua Hillsboro nine also known as Ward
5 Nashua this is my third term at the
New Hampshire state house also my third
time on the public works and highways
committee
um when I first arrived at the State
House you had to write down your
preferences for Wards I mean for
committees
they had three entries I wrote four I
didn't get any of them but I did get a
phone call one night from John Cloutier
and that was the best thing that ever
happened because I'm really happy to be
on the Public Works in highways
committee and as the the former chair
described it it's very collegial and I
thought that was a good choice of words
that he had
and um
um
I am a retired software engineer I am
widowed with three adult children one of
them lives right here in Concord and um
uh
I also serve on the Nashua city planning
board and some carryover from this
committee to that is there's an
applicant in town he wants to put in a
plant with like
lots and lots of very heavy trucks and I
think knowledge that I've learned on
this committee will carry over to
helping make better decisions on the
national city planning board
I'm Mark delone I represent the town of
Epping my grandfather Tom facto served
on this Committee in the 1930s and my
son Matthew served one term in 2002 on
this committee as well he was elected
out of saint
Anselm College I don't know if you
remember him I'm a retired principal I
served on the education commission my
first term I went to this committee
simply because there's some some really
serious needs in Epping I've served on
the zba I'm currently on the budget
committee and this looks like a fine
bunch of people and I'm so happy to be
I'm very
excuse me I should have done that before
Barry walked from Swansea uh represent
Swansea and Richmond that's my fourth
term and fourth term on this committee
I am semi-retired I still practice land
use law and Keene
my original interest in this committee
was because of my prior career 30 30
plus years in transportation planning I
worked on a lot of developing a lot of
Highway and Transit projects including a
lot of work for the MBTA
I have served on the Monadnock Regional
School Board on planning boards and
other Municipal committees
and uh just a pair of things this
wouldn't claimed the famous I'm a fifth
generation Walker to serve in the house
proud to do that
and I've been married 51 years and two
children and three grandchildren from
foreign
yes my name is Michael Abbott and I
represent Cheshire District Six which is
consists of the towns of Chesterfield
Hinsdale and Westmoreland
um
in my prior life I spent 30 years as 15
as a social studies teacher and 15 as a
principal
at Hinsdale high school
I'm I was very interested I'm starting
my fifth term
but I was very interested in being on
public works and highways although my
first term I
wasn't able to get on I was on a
transportation committee which did give
me some contacts with the dot and
to figure out a little bit about what
was going on and I I do enjoy serving on
this committee because it has been
spoken about
by a number of the members
it is a bipartisan
um
committee and usually we don't have any
trouble
convincing the whole house to go around
along with what our recommendation is uh
that unfortunately sometimes the Senate
does not file a course
I'm I'm married for 47 years I have won
a child a child who is now an adult and
two grandchildren
I hope we continue that the progress we
uh
I served in the U.S Air Force as an
intelligence agent
I was stationed Okinawa
I broke my area responsibility of
Beijing and I broke two of the codes
they've been working on for 20 years in
four months
when I left the service
I sold cars for a few years
now they decided I wanted to go into
Construction
so it did
I ended up designing and building over
100 commercial industrial buildings in
three states
and then we went belly up under uh one
of those recessions Bush the old the
bush recession
uh USB one to keep me going but I didn't
want to do it
so I started a
Discount Store got up to four stores
took me a while I only had eleven
dollars a wife and four kids when I
started
so it was
we so start selling furniture to get
started anyway
uh this is my fourth term
first term I was on Health and Human
Services and that was a zoo
nobody talked to anybody
they just argued all the time so this
was a absolute Delight to get on this
committee we'll at least we can talk to
people
we don't always have to agree
but we do most of the time eventually
and that's what I like about this
committee
uh
yes hello my name is Sue Newman and I am
honored to be here with all of you
gentlemen I can bring a woman's
perspective to sound barriers rumble
strips
roads Bridges dams and I think over the
time that I've spent on this committee
and in doing some traveling with my
husband who's also a rep he's on
criminal justice and I know what you
mean about some of the drama on other
committees
I have noticed sound barriers throughout
the country
some of which are fairly spectacular and
I'll leave it at that I was a realtor in
Southern New Hampshire uh serving the
Nashua area I represent nashua's Ward 2.
so I was a realtor for 25 years I served
eight years on the Nashua School Board
my hair was brown then
um and we have children that are grown
we have wonderful grandchildren and I
will just say when all of you chose to
be on this committee I didn't I had no
idea what it was I chose three other
worthwhile committees I thought and I
got here and it's been a it's really
been a good experience thank you
um
Stephen bogert I represent Laconia
I'm currently on the Zoning Board of
adjustments for Laconia for 20 years 18
years as a chairperson the I'm also the
ward five Ward clerk for elections
within the town and I'm also the
treasurer for the Laconia youth football
and cheer Association for 18 years
it's been quite exciting to be up here
in Laconia prior to that I worked 30
years with Motorola down in Fort
Lauderdale Florida where I had the
opportunity to also work and and and
learn about planning and zoning and I
became also a City Commissioner within
as a side note I was one of six
Republicans that requested to sit in a
center section of
the house
and the reason I picked the center
section is I wanted to have an
opportunity to see all the different
viewpoints that are coming across us
we've had too much division over the
years and I think
since 80 percent of the same people are
both are ninety percent of the same
people are both Democrats and
Republicans
that have
the same wants and things that this
would be a good place uh Public Works I
find uh
I was
unsure of
but I'm looking forward to working with
it because I've had a lot of planning
experience and stuff we've built a city
that was 40 percent built to build out
of 60 percent which was approximately 10
square miles and we've had to learn how
to set up codes how to set up roadways
how to set up intersections and and how
to manage the different uh requirements
for when the development happened and it
was quite exciting so I was hoping that
maybe some of my experience would be
able be of some use and if not I'm
hoping to learn a whole lot of new stuff
hi I'm Richard Baldwin I represent
District Six which encompasses Guildford
Gilmanton and Ward 2 Laconia
this will be my second time in the house
and also my second time on pwh
I'm hoping that we can work together and
thank you thank you one and all and for
the new members a couple items I think
it's in I think it's worthwhile for the
new members to hear what the history is
and you can see that many of us whether
you're you're a new member or a seasoned
person has had a lot of involvement in
your community served on boards and that
sort of thing so following procedure
from the chairman I think should be
rather easy for you so I throw that
um representative Abbott throughout a a
very important thing that I probably
should have brought up
it has been a long history of this
committee and it's because of the work
we do together and that we find resolve
and that we we come up with
bills that are are strong that we are
very rarely questioned on the floor when
it comes time to present our two
Hallmark bills one being in the capital
budget which we're going to work on this
year and next year will be the 10-year
10-year
Transportation plan
so
we we I put it out there we're thought
highly in other committees and so I want
you to know that you're coming into a
group that in all honesty when we step
on the floor is well thought out
represent Newman I did not realize it
until you mentioned you're the only lady
in the room this Teresa evil and others
are are off to uh to other tasks
um I'm going to um
run through a few things that you may
have already been told about during your
first organizational days but our our
committee room is to the right members
staff only each and every one of you has
a pull-out Locker that you can keep your
your materials in there should be a coat
rack in there if it turns out we don't
have enough accommodation
then please let me know and we'll figure
that out there's also coat racks out in
in the hallways there is a committee
chairman by chairman room that is part
of part of there also we ask that there
are no electronic devices left on the
table
when we are out here some of the members
will need to have
uh Clerk and others might have a laptop
and that sort of thing but during all
hearings we want we want the people to
be welcome here and they I want them to
as the speaker does know that you're
giving everyone their full attention and
we're not answering text messages and so
forth and if you need to do it if it's
important to your business and just
please just get out of your chair and
walk into the committee room or or the
hallway
uh no coffee no food on on the counters
they do permit water if you have special
needs or things that you have to have at
hand let me know and we'll we'll work
that out
there is a chart on the wall over there
I'll double check that that talks about
how we get out of here in the event of a
fire emergency
or a Security emergency so it is up
thank you thank Chris appreciate that so
I'll need everyone to pay attention to
that I don't think we have to do the
airline showing you which door we're
going to leave but please uh there there
tends to be
um one day in a session that they will
sound alarm and make sure we all know
all know where to go
we have not chosen yet although
representative Newman is is showing much
urgency in this position but the
um the far the far right seat uh next to
the door is is typically the person we
assign I don't know what the official
title is but we will come up with one
our security individual in in the event
that during testimony or for some reason
we have a health emergency
we'd alert the person on the far right
seat who will then contact security and
and keep things moving forward
we they've talked about a word the word
typically has been Hawk when we ask for
Mr Hawk then that's that's when the
the person on the last seat jumps to
alert and runs out of the room
so
um our seating assignment is uh is
hybrid at this point uh speaker has
asked that we mingle in and out every
other or so forth Republican Democrat
I've sort of worked uh the front table
here if if you're sitting somewhere that
is not comfortable for you or you have
needs where you need to leave the room
uh for some some certain reason then
just please let me know and we'll make
arrangement and so by the time we meet
next time uh we will have it
um in stone where everyone's going to be
sitting the microphones
um they um because we are live
um you need to press your uh I think
most of you just have one button and uh
turn it on and turn it off when you
speak and when you're finished
the
the makeup of our committee is 20
members the members that are not here
had already called in today and said
that they weren't going to be here for
one reason or the other
we asked that I asked that if you cannot
make the meeting or a hearing or you're
going to be running 20 minutes late but
you are coming in or something please a
text works best for me but please get in
chart get in touch with myself with John
or with David so we know where we are if
you know ahead of time that you have a
week away that you've already scheduled
first first term people and or business
that's coming up as much notice as we
can get would be preferable
uh first time I came to the house one
election my wife and I and our kids had
already lined up a trip to Disney I
wasn't going to be here for inauguration
day I don't know if
um you folks know the name Gene Chandler
he was first time speaker at the time
and I had mentioned to the speaker that
I wasn't going to be there for
inauguration and if you knew the
gentleman he had very very dry sense of
humor and Gene turned to me and said
well you should be so I made
arrangements to fly my family come back
and then go back again only to find out
after 20 years he says Mark you never
had to do that so
so I'm just saying if you can't if you
can't be here please just let us know
ahead of time
the um we have posted I'm sure you all
know about the calendar
our notices have to come out of this
room by Wednesday to make it into the
calendar we've posted our first hearings
which will be John on the 20th Wednesday
the 25th right starting at 10 A.M 25th
and I have we have 14 bills before our
committee right now we're hoping to take
the first seven on the first day and I
have a schedule here that I've shared
with uh with John and with David which
would be the following Friday where we
would handle the next seven
we have a conflict if we're picking the
27th because Rockingham County as their
executive committee meaning that they at
all okay so 27th and it's special except
nine o'clock so we can't okay sounds
good we'll we'll work through that we so
we have our first we will most likely be
the following Monday I would think
we um we'll figure that out and and let
you know many of you are have businesses
or still work and
um so I'm trying to stay ahead of the
schedule the capital budget the governor
will release that officially has to
release it I Believe by February 15th
they're about
um we have
I've had some conversations with his uh
budget director
it looks like our numbers at least at
this point will be somewhere somewhat
that we've seen him in the past
120 million dollars or so
um there were rumors that it was going
to be a much lesser number but it looks
like we have a comfortable number the
treasure will be one of the first people
that comes in we'll talk about our
responsible
bonding how that comes about and so
forth so
we will be we will deliberate we will
hear our bills we will get our bills
done well ahead of the February deadline
because once we go into the capital
budget we will spend four or five days
hearing from the agencies
and we will probably then spend nearly
as much time than
um discussing their budget needs so we
will have a very intense schedule
um through February and mid-march
and then of course we always have to
work around the days we're in session
and so forth
so that's that's sort of
our schedule on our first day I think we
start at 10 o'clock and our last hearing
is at um three o'clock three o'clock so
it's always a chore for a chairman to
figure how much time it's it's going to
be for each and every one so hopefully
past experience helps a little so we
don't have too much dead time there we
do have a request what day did I say
we're going to do that
we had we had a request from
to do a site visit
just around the corner Department of
Education wants to move into new digs
and I scheduled that tentatively
for that Friday so I have to move it
um because it's just down the road I
thought we'd go take a peek at what
their facilities that they want to move
so I know everyone should be well versed
on you know at least what's coming in
for the first when we talk about public
hearings
I find especially important that we be
as courteous that's what we're here to
to hear testimony I do not
um and it has never been the policy of a
chairman in this committee to allow
members to debate or engage
persons that are here with testimony if
you have if you have questions
department heads or a question a
clarifying question that's fine but I
will not permit anyone that has taken
their time
to sit here before us to uh
to have anything but courtesy uh thrown
on top of them
and that has always been the case here
anyways any questions that you have as
members
um you raise your hand I will recognize
you or the vice chairman and if neither
of us in the room the clerk will
recognize you and then you will you will
ask your question
we we do not operate under Robert's
Rules
and we keep it cheerful between us and
and everything works well if you have a
follow-up question you will ask for the
follow-up question if you don't the
chairman of one of these gentlemen will
ask you uh probably to suspend so
especially new members don't get
concerned we will we will all get
everyone through here and I'm sure the
other members will will help you as we
go
uh if they're if you have a bill out
there that you are co-sponsoring you are
the sponsor you will leave you will
leave the uh
your chair you will sit in the audience
um and you won't you won't participate
in questioning of of the others
if you have a conflict of interest you
um roll calls executive session will
will all pull that as we go uh John do
you have uh representative Cloutier do
you have anything else you'd like to add
um not uh I mean when person comes to
testify they have to fill out a pink
card including yourselves if you're
testifying before this committee you
have to fill a pink car with your name
address how about how long you think
you're going to be with testimony
and you submit it and if you have
written testimony the clerk appreciates
it very much uh because our clerks you
know I've been a clerk and it's not an
easy job not a job that everybody wants
but to make the clerk's job a little bit
easier if you have it please uh you know
and maybe pass out the copies well ahead
of time and but in any case if you have
your just one copy you know the clerk
would appreciate a copy at the end of
your testimony
um as far as recognizing people uh I
mean I'm just and I'm marking on how you
do it but the first person who raises a
hand I will recognize you sometimes
there's a bunch of people I write a list
down to keep a track in my head because
sometimes I'm trying to follow stuff and
it's not easy and if I forget just
politely ask me that you have a question
and remind me when I try to take it and
the order I see your hand raised so if
if for example representative Newman
raises her hand first she goes first uh
Representatives under fidolfi if he's
next same thing and I've I've watched
cheers over the years and I write a list
of last names if they're into a way for
me to keep track especially a lot of you
have questions
um I can't think of anything else at the
moment Mr chairman thank you
David do you have anything dead at this
point
um uh no sir I just want to go over two
things
because I have to call roll call on a
lot of these things and I want to make
sure I've got these last two names it's
vallone
the loan and
Baldwin
I'm done those are ones I had problems
with unless I've been saying anybody
else is wrong for the last 10 years
representative
I think it might be helpful if you
explain uh
that when you're recognized to ask the
question you ask one question and then
if you have something to follow on you
asked to be recognized again or for
follow-up
um and the other thing I'll make you
who who can or who does see the video
and and audio feed and
just so people are aware that there's an
audience out there
excellent points so
um
unless unless you're told otherwise when
you're when you're in this room
take the stance that you're being
recorded we will because there's is
there a red light or anything that's
telling us something's going on here I
don't think there is so if you're in
this room
um and it is there have been you're
being filmed and it's going out and so
private conversation take it private and
especially if you're caught on a hot mic
that's that's not a good thing so you
recognize for the question as Robson
Fogg said if you have a follow-up Mr
chairman my follow-up is uh but just
don't keep just don't keep rolling
through
um
represent Mills will be calling the roll
call as we go I'm I will come right back
to you I'm notoriously horrible with
last names
that's just that's just part of my uh of
who I am so if I get stuck and we're in
a committee and I pointed to the
representative or call for someone else
please go with me we'll we'll find our
way through
um a question
thank you Mr chairman so just to clarify
so if we testify on a bill that we're
having a hearing on we're done for that
hearing we have to stay in the audience
we don't come back to our chair is that
correct that's that's my understanding
yes great executive session needless to
say you're allowed back at your chair
okay but the the idea is to contain
asking questions on on your own
anyone else with questions at this point
yes sir
just the clarification if you're
testifying on a bill you only step aside
for the
that bill only once that bill has been
heard you can come back to sit that
would be true sir thank you
representative Newman
and if we're having an executive session
it will be noticed ahead of time
yes thank you
the um the rules as I understand them is
that we're to give four days notice
our our and I'll come back to you our we
we have naming bills especially in this
uh that's one of our charges and and
many times
um it will be for a lost family member
or something and we may have in the
audience family members that have
traveled here and I don't because see I
did not put this on our first notice but
I want to make sure it goes out
Wednesday that we may exec on all of
those bills but I'll make that as a
courtesy we we try and exec those bills
other questions
yes I'm sorry please go ahead
it looks it looks like Mondays and
Fridays well
well conflict with that with
the county commissions because they're
so used to every
everyone's name there's Thursdays that
that they try and schedule okay
so we we lost Tuesday in here because of
the transportation committee so we'll
fill in on days then on Tuesday so we're
saying Tuesday Wednesday Thursday and
Thursday so we'll does that work for you
sir
Fridays are not good
Fridays for other members an issue
counties
okay we're in it we're in a tough spot
where we're sharing a room it was always
so much easier and we had one room and
we could work on our day so
um I will sit with the vice chairman and
the clerk uh when we finish to push that
on to a new day that works for us but
once County County work you should
actually be done in a couple months
won't you depending on what your
yeah so
all right a lot of things moving yes sir
uh just a some information due to the
county budget and stuff coming February
Wednesdays it looks like we're trying to
cover our from a county delegation uh
the budgets from one to five each of
those Wendy's Wednesdays of February
I don't know if that'll have any adverse
effect
yeah every every County's different
um we my Carroll County we tend to uh
meet on Mondays and when we have
conflicts with the house then we meet on
Saturdays so perhaps you folks could let
us know where you know where where your
county schedules are
um
I view the most important work is done
in this room in the county is second but
we will we will we will work that out
anyone else with questions
yes representative thank you chair you
mentioned uh reviewing capital budget uh
it's going to be intense from the middle
of February until about the middle of
March uh and that would
be Tuesday through Thursday for the most
part
is that how it looks at this point we
would we would meet two to three days a
week okay and then there'll be there
might be a house session in there
working around that yeah same same sort
of schedule we'll start for nine o'clock
or ten o'clock and go to at least three
o'clock in the afternoon
trying to schedule our hearings uh so
that we can get an hour break for uh
lunch usually somewhere around noon to
one o'clock
if you have dietary needs and and things
are running and you it's you need to
have food then
off off to the committee room you go
let's see what else I have
um
I'll I'll hold it for the next time
yes amendments to bills now normally
when we have an amendment to the bill we
we take it up before the main bill that
the practice in our committee at least
although some committees are different
but normally most amendments we don't
have a roll call vote right and we we
vote on but we may do a Voice vote for
an amendment and then do a roll call on
the bill itself and if it's amended as
on the bill is amended right I mean
that's this one that can clear to
everybody how we handle amendments more
amendments excuse me amendments to
legislation we have before us to to
consider an amendment it has to be in
writing and and gone through the process
and brought back to this committee room
with a seal on it and I'm sure that was
discussed uh other times amendments will
be brought up if you recognized in the
amendment uh will be brought forward and
it does not have to be a roll call so uh
um a hand count or uh some and there was
a controversy a few years back that one
of our I think officials former house
clerk said that everything amendments
had to be a roll call and I guess at the
time I think that our one of our chair
get back here I hate to use the name
chairman Chandler disagreed and our
process had been any amendments normal
unless it's a major issue that we do
just The Voice vote on amendments but a
roll call on a main a bill and if it's
amended the bill as amended I just want
to clarify that that's that's correct
and before we before we go into our
first executive session will will go
through all the all the procedures and
and how and how that is done
yes go right ahead thank you uh the
former chair of the committee uh David
Campbell of Nashua is the Corporation
Council at the New Hampshire North Coast
Railroad and he's been kind enough to
bring us calendars full of pictures of
trains there on the table here and
foreign
I I really don't have anything else at
this point unless John you do or David
at this point uh we will the only other
thing if you don't thank you Mr chairman
about executive sessions that when we
have an executive session that normally
that's the time the public it's a public
meeting the public can stay here but
they it's no longer testimony time they
basically it's our show and it's us an
opportunity for committee members to
debate a bill ask questions but unless
we need some information normally we
don't they're supposed to keep their
mouth you know quiet to be honest with
you right that's the practice for any
executive session I think some members
get a little confused about what an
executive session is versus a public
hearing and executive session normally
isn't a continuation of a public hearing
if I understand it
that would be correct
and and we'll we'll cover all of that at
that point in time
um I have some other handouts that we
can pass along for the newer members so
you understand how that process works
and uh clerk will be sending that out to
yes executive sessions are also being a
streamed live as well I think okay
thank you
when you're when you're in this room
eyes are on you
so the um
if you have I I'll tell I'll tell
another item so there is on our web on
our general court website when you go to
standing committees uh then you go to
public works and there's a listing of
all all of our members there
I have sent out a notice to each one of
you through your legislative
emails uh testing to see if we have the
contact information
and um
I just have two members and Lou
um
if you can come up to me and give me a
phone number for yourself
and I'd prefer to have cell numbers
these this list will stay in our
committee so some of you don't want to
have those things these will stay in our
committee
um
I need some more information from you I
got Clifford's information
Dan Eaton I need a phone number
um when we when we finish if you could
just come up to the desk here and just
well actually I think I have everybody
else
I do have everyone else so don't don't
be afraid to contact me
um I
text is easiest
a phone call will get returned an email
works fantastic because I'm always going
through those all day long in in my
business setting
so
um without if there's any other
questions just please give me a call
text do whatever you want to do I'm
available
for the new members if there's a passion
item that you want to talk about
uh please do I just want you to know if
you're the first time member here just
sitting on this committee does not let
your pet project run through where we
are you need to make consensus there's a
10-year plan to be followed and we tend
to be very strict on that
but I'm here there's all sorts of uh
seniority here that just please ask
questions whatever we can do we will do
all right
with that
we will
um we will end the orientation and we
will be back in
uh in committee for the Wednesday
January 25th at 10 A.M at 10 A.M all
right
that'll do us
foreign